we're now on the road to the secret
destination one day soon you guys will
figure out what this project is and I
can't wait for you to see it it's
basically something where I'm going
somewhere and I don't know anything
about what I'm doing so it's one of
those things think that it's gonna be
cool
try not to phone on the way home so many
good jams money
beg me to open this is a feat all this
is a nice subtle jail nice - nice turn
down one okay go you can't you cannot
call my phone what I'm freaking listen
to tunes on my road trip throwing
everything
I mean my goodness sighs I am so sick
right now like myself until one we had
that's 1 p.m.
just for the record we did our shoot
last night it was from like 5 p.m. until
like 4:30 a.m. I got back to the hotel I
feel like I just got the flu like my
entire body hurts so bad I couldn't even
take a shower I did I managed but taking
a shower was actually painful like
trying to brush my hair oh my god this
is that so bad I hardly ever get sick so
when I do it's like holy crap my body is
shutting down we have another night
shoot tonight and I think it's gonna be
also pretty late or early the drive over
here was really pretty uh put my clothes
on I mean I have my clothes on I took my
shoes on and then I'm gonna go to
Starbucks hopefully with that hopefully
that will help me God my shirt looks so
good though looks so good
hi how's it going I'm still sick
Maddie just dragged this bed all the way
into here from the kitchen out of his
cage I was sleeping and I woke up on my
place why is all this ruckus and it's
Maddie
just wake me up hey honey and tomorrow
we have to go to my sister's
bachelorette party in Vegas like I'm not
sure how I'm gonna be able to pack look
at you I'm gonna take care of Mommy hmm
hey give me keys please
Jenna's coming back over so hopefully I
can convince her to give him a bath cuz
I can't I can hardly even hold this
phone off so I'm still sick I'm so sick
I could only have brushed my hair my
whole body hurts I think going to Vegas
is quite possibly the worst idea that up
I've ever had ever
this is like the only thing that we've
actually had to plan to like we don't
plan and this is what happens when you
point but we're doing for Bree you're
doing it for free free girl bounties on
the rest the story no well we're our
flights in an hour
ha ha ha our flight is in an hour and we
haven't even dropped Matty offered his
babysitter yet the drives and driver
Garrett all these things oh come on I
love you remember the last time I ate I
packed for oatmeal bars and a whole box
of glass bars but I don't think you
should I don't think that's good for my
tummy right now this is the final stop
I'm not going to that I'm sorry this is
we have a stripper pole we made it to
the Venetian and we have an awesome
suite and basically saying exactly what
Jenna said in her vlog we put the party
people in another room because clearly
this is not a party happening we're now
loft to ride the gondola gondola gondola
gondola you forgot how much I love
my favorite little parts I don't I'll
shout each like Whitaker's like the real
light actually a good question I'm not
sure yeah guys we're getting on this
boat okay first up on the inside all
right everybody please wear your
seatbelt I think you guys are famous cuz
we have a paparazzi
go to your bachelorette party
briefly hunter talking love that's
slowly oh my gosh how cute YouTube mrs.
Baker that's yes look at everyone I feel
like I want oh my god guys I don't know
when I've been this eyeglass
holy moly I've been trying to pull
together and go to events and have fun I
actually had a lot of fun on the gondola
ride Oerlikon gondola gondola caution I
keep miss mounting it I've always wanted
to ride on that
so I finally did and it was really fun
to get to do it for pretties
bachelorette party right now they are I
can't even make this up there at thunder
down under' I told you how to film me a
little video so hopefully I'll have a
nice little clip to show you what I'm
missing
Vegas is not a good place to be when you
are not well what have I done so this
was probably the worst vlog in the world
I'm sorry to feel better so I think
hopefully the next one I might venture
outside of the bed I've been here for a
long time over 24 hours so we are still
in Vegas I am finally almost over my
sickness but I'm still not hundred
percent we are at Mandalay Bay going to
see the Cirque show Michael Jackson won
and I actually have not seen this one so
I'm really excited to be it is one the
best one free how's your bachelorette
party but everyone's like where's my
muse yeah we have to book where's free
and if nobody attended you're fighting
it's my party brazen party and super
hard and I've literally been in bed for
like 48 hours I'm getting the tummy
virus sorry we'll go see this okay
there's a tattoo parlor oh my god done
we have 25 minutes let's do it
what happened here's the theater shows
about to start and I'm not allowed to
film in here and I'm already breaking
the rules we had so much fun seeing the
Cirque show honestly even if you don't
know a single Michael Jackson song which
I'm pretty sure all of you know at least
one song I think he would absolutely
enjoyed show I wasn't able to film too
much the show they tell used to cameras
on the way right now and head back and
go to sleep because give another
fun-filled day tomorrow
Marie's bachelorette party hopefully I'm
feeling better so I can actually partake
in the adventures
good morning this has been a crazy trip
this is just one long vlog everybody's
wearing they're just drunk general I
have our maid of honor I'm not drunk
I've been eating it probiotics and
drinking Pedialyte so good morning
there is get that little shirts on it's
so cute and briefs got her drunk in love
relook you we're going to breakfast now
oh my god I am venturing out of the way
no last supper rustling great Vegas it's
a great place I feel great put that on a
t-shirt
so we're back here making some more
suspects have the sash one button drinks
it's going to be pretty exciting they
don't know what they're in flower we eat
an entire flowers and include the
destination ever taste in your life but
is the
oh my god I get it online
wild
we're off to Lavo now it's one of our
favorite restaurants to go to
in blot fill prospective addition where
we're staying so it's always so easy to
just go between the two I'm finally
feeling better like today I was able to
eat normal I felt like the normal human
yeah right because you were not welcome
today here on Bever we kind of walked
around today a few things now we're
going to eat and then I'm going to go to
bed and then Maddie has to go for a
blood test tomorrow and then he goes to
get his balls cut off Monday snip listen
it
the garlic bread is king yes there's so
much Riddle asleep right now
raising can you believe it let's wrap on
Vegas we're all taking probiotics and
drinking Pedialyte right now it's it's
got to that I'm afraid I might have
gotten all my friends sick I hope not
I'll be all right I think we did ate too
much I regret nothing I'll see you guys
in the next video sorry I didn't the
cooking is a to have one for Thursday
but since I was traveling I had to make
edits to it and I didn't have the files
with me so I wasn't able to post it so
I'll post that next Thursday I'm gonna
go to sleep we get to see Maddie -
morning so that's our gondola gondola
gondola gondola you look so happy
I was so ill you were not well very very
carefully